you hear the power of that voice
nobody's heard that voice before
he doesn't do news conferences they fish
you haven't heard and this was a special
moment and this is I think really the
president would said this is a historic
moment the fact that we're meeting and I
want to thank chairman Kim for something
else when I put out the social media and
notification if he didn't show up
the press was gonna make me look very
bad so you made us both look good and I
appreciate it but we've developed a
great relationship I really think that
if you go back to what I have years and
you look at what was going on prior to
my becoming president it was a very very
bad situation a very dangerous situation
for South Korea for North Korea for the
world and I think the relationship that
we've developed has has meant so much to
so many people and it's just an honor to
be with you it was an honor that you
asked me to step over that line that I
was proud to step over the line I
thought you might do that I wasn't sure
but I was ready to do it and I want to
thank you it's been great things like
burning historic they were just saying
one of the folks from the media would
say this could be a very just a moment
that I guess that's what it is but I
enjoy being with you
you